tonight on Brian Ross investigates it's
a special holy week for one of the
world's fastest-growing church claiming
more than 5 million members across the
US and around the world but its leader
called the Apostle is nowhere to be seen
he's behind bars awaiting trial in Los
Angeles on sex trafficking charges
involving teenage girls in his church
naked during sexual affairs and now one
of his accusers has filed a landmark
lawsuit against nason joaquin garcia
claiming she was coerced into becoming
his sex slave and a recruiter for other
young women you can't tell him no you
can't tell him this isn't right we'll be
joined live by social Martin and her
lawyers ready to blow the whistle on the
apostle and what they call his corrupt
Church plus our shoutout for the
reporter in Louisville Kentucky who
exposed how police in that city target
innocent black drivers on routine
traffic stops why so many black drivers
get much more than a simple traffic
ticket ordered out of the car handcuffed
their vehicles searched from the law and
crime Network studios in New York City's
Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investigates good evening and welcome we
begin tonight with new allegations about
the leader of one of the world's fastest
growing churches called the light of the
world and now one of the women who was
in his inner circle has laid bare the
sordid details of what she says was
going on behind the scenes in a lawsuit
filed in California she and her lawyers
will be joining us shortly for the light
of the world Church and the 5 million
plus members it claims this is its big
week a festival called
the holy supper to honor the birthday of
one of its first leaders a
self-proclaimed apostle of Jesus it
should be a big time for the current
apostle the grandson of the founder
but he won't be there Nessun joaquin
garcia is in jail in los angeles
awaiting trial on sex trafficking
charges involving teenage girls who were
members of his church one of them was
this woman so Jill Martin who in a new
lawsuit filed today says she was
recruited as a teenager manipulated to
become his sex slave and a recruiter of
other underage children unable she told
us in an earlier interview to say no you
can't tell him to stop you can't tell
him no you can't tell him this isn't
right you can't tell him it hurts you
can't tell him you can't tell him that
you're unhappy you can't tell you can't
tell him that you're in pain you can't
tell him that you're confused you can't
say any of that
there are various dimensions to this
case it's a human rights case it's a
case about the sexual abuse of children
but it is also a case about organized
crime as detailed in the complaint that
we filed la Luz del mundo is a massive
global organization that for decades has
systematically exploited its members in
ways that are not only gross violations
of human rights but are also federal and
state crimes and joining us now from
California is social Martin and her
lawyer Deborah now grave social year
lawsuit is a chronicle of alleged sexual
depravity include involving the so
called apostle what it calls a lifetime
of manipulation and abuse of a young
woman perpetrated by sexual predators
and the global institution built around
and for the protection of those
predators so social this is about more
than just the apostle yes it is thank
you Brian for for having us and it is
much more about just the apostille it's
about an institution a corrupt
institution that enable this apostille
so call apostille and help him commit
these crimes and it needs to stop
and social you say you were raped
several times and beaten severely as you
told me in our earlier interview yes
right and that's part of this complaint
Debra no grave let me ask you you don't
allegedly complain about sexual
trafficking here you talk about issues
in terms of how she was manipulated and
coerced into becoming a sexual servant
that's correct correct a sexual servant
and as well as forced labor and other
crimes and where does that case go with
that that kind of allegation against not
only Garcia but many around him the
hierarchy of the church with the
complaint and with the litigation we're
trying to expose a criminal organization
not just it's the Apostle in a song but
the entire organization and its
leadership and bring to light so
everyone can see what this organization
really is it uses religion as a front to
bring in innocent victims to gain their
trust and in coerce them into situations
such as the trafficking forced labor and
often yes sexual abuse we have a
question for you from our control room
from the executive producer Rhonda
Schwartz Rhonda
so social even before you filed this
lawsuit the church has been attacking
you they scammed that you were involved
in recruiting other young woman to be
abused by the Apostle what do you say
about that it's all part of the
manipulation that the this organization
does and and it keeps happening but it's
obvious why this has to stop and why
somebody has to have a voice and like
many people out there many victims and
survivors of ldm and who've chosen to
stay quiet and not so much as they chose
to they're being silenced and it's all
because of the crimes that they make you
do by the orders of mezon you don't have
a choice
socially you told me and you say in your
complaint that you actually
been followed by people who are sort of
infamous henchmen of the church you felt
threatened by that yes yes of course
they have stopped us they stayed outside
of our house they've recorded us they've
had two men come in and out of the
outside of the parameters of our
property they vandalized our home
they've followed us to different places
where we were from that's why we had to
leave our home and Ensenada and on
social media they've just harassed us my
husband my daughter and myself and so do
you fear that there will be
ramifications from bringing this lawsuit
now that is the hope I hope that do I
fear that there will be ramifications um
I'm sorry I yeah before you think about
something else that's the hope no that's
not the hope I do fear just because
these people they will do anything that
nason asks them to do and even behind
bars he's a very dangerous person
it's not just Nason all on it's all on
his own he has a team of of people who
will do anything for him and whatever he
says goes
and yeah I'm scared but I feel I feel
protected
Deborah no grave let me ask you as such
Hills lawyer the fact that she has
brought the suit shows a kind of courage
in her part was it difficult to get to
this point
I will say it hasn't been easy but Miss
Martin is committed and she's extremely
strong and extremely brave so she's been
very forthcoming and eager to kind of
work with us and quite frankly it has
been for at least the past three years
since she has stopped going to services
within Lalo's de mundo
she has been threatened and suffered
from severe harassment and so she says
while she fears that going forward it's
a it's a great moment of standing up and
this was her way of fighting back but
you are taking a very powerful and
wealthy organization in bringing this
lawsuit well you know the road through
righteousness is not always easy but
sometimes it is what needs to be done
and so - let me ask you finally you talk
about being afraid you've you've paid a
price already haven't you in breaking
with the church and breaking with the
so-called apostle well besides my safety
issue
I've lost friends family home community
I lost everything
but it's like my attorney said there are
there is a price to pay for coming
forward and to fight for justice and
nobody says it's going to be easy and
that's a battle that I'm ready to take
on and you're committed to keep going
yes I am because no one did it for me
and I'm ready to have the voice for all
of those little ones that don't have
that voice all right well thank you so
much social Martin and Deborah now brave
for joining us
we asked church officials and Lawrence
for the church leader to also be on our
program tonight but they declined the
offer stands and we're eager to hear
their side of the story as well thank
you both when we turn as the Harvey
Weinstein case goes to the jury some are
asking has the me2 movement gone too far
we're joined by two lawyers who
lead the way in taking on powerful men
and institutions accused of covering up
widespread sexual misconduct
the case against Harvey Weinstein once
one of the most powerful men in
Hollywood will go to the jury next week
more than 80 women have made allegations
against him involving sexual abuse
attack and rape and the case is being
closely watched with Weinstein allegedly
telling the associates that he
essentially is the victim that the me2
movement has gone too far so joining us
to talk about that now our two lawyers
who are helping to lead the way and
taking on powerful men and institutions
who have tried to cover up sexual abuse
of young people over the years here in
the studio Daniel Barker who's currently
suing USA Swimming on behalf of a young
girl who was sexually abused by her
coach and by Skype from California
Joshua Robbins a former federal
prosecutor who's now part of that legal
team bringing the case on behalf of
social Martin against the light of the
world Church and mr. Robbins let me
begin with you
how important will diverted in the
Weinstein case be for lawsuits like miss
Martin's I think that that case in any
other high-profile case in this space is
going to send a message to many about
the about how these cases are going to
be treated if you'd buy both the jury
and the public so I think it's going to
be significant across the number of
these types of cases and mr. Juan Cena
said that me too movement has gone too
far do you buy that I think that's a
pretty broad statement I don't think
anyone I don't think anyone can suggest
that righting the wrongs that have been
committed against half of the human race
for any number of decades and centuries
can be said to be going too far I think
it's a movement whose time has come and
and there's going to be more to come
from it and Daniel Barker here in New
York you're taking on a powerful
institution as Josh Robbins in
California going against that church and
against going against Harvey Weinstein
here in New York it's still not easy is
it it is not it very much feels like a
David and Goliath situation these
institutions have been around for a long
time the problem has been around for a
long time
we're just now being able to make
inroads to try to hold the institutions
accountable and we see in the Weinstein
case what you might call victim blaming
right that goes down a lot doesn't it it
does I think it I think it can be
effective and when the defense strategy
involves that and I think as long as
things are effective that's what we see
being done
Josh Robbins in California do you see
that in in this case they've already
started to launch an attack on social
Martin as somebody who's been involved
in they say her own criminal misconduct
I don't think we're surprised at all
about that as Miss Martin can tell you
herself because she was part of it for
many years the church has an established
and very powerful propaganda machine
they can put out any number of
statements to smear anyone who goes up
against it we've expected that we expect
to see more of that and obviously it's
not something that is deterred her in
this case and when you take on a big
church like that with lots of resources
lots of money what are the unique
difficulties there are many difficulties
obviously in putting a case together
given the complexity of the organization
how long this is going on and for how
many years how many people it is
involved and obviously in finding
witnesses with the courage to come
forward but frankly that's nothing
compared to the difficulties that
someone like Miss Martin herself has had
to undergo in the years that she was
victimized by that institution and in
coming forward to take it on herself she
is the brave one here we can't claim to
be that and when you talk about sexual
misconduct of powerful people you have
to be careful in choosing a jury right
there are efforts sometimes to blame the
victims that we're talking about no
question you see that in you've seen
that of mr. Weinstein's case you see
that in a number of cases there is an
attempt to change the story to change
the narrative and to make allegations
against the victim or the survivor in
this case to try to change that story we
don't think that that's going to be
successful it generally isn't you don't
know we certainly don't think it will be
in this case and given just the volume
and the years of abuse that this
organization has engaged in I think that
they're going to have a tough task
trying to make that work
Daniel Barker
ask you when you go against a powerful
institution there's an effort somehow to
say well they knew what they're getting
into whether it's these young women or
their parents right I think as we learn
more as a society about about these
kinds of claims it will become in time
more difficult to blame the victims I
mean it's it's time we do something as a
society just stop what's happening and
you think this kind of lawsuit is the
answer to that I do I really do if we
don't hold institutions and individuals
responsible for what they do even if
they've done it for a long time then
there's not any incentive for them to
change and Josh Robbins let me ask you
as a former federal prosecutor is the
government doing enough to go after
these cases why is it left up to civil
lawsuits to resolve this well I think
the government has in a number of cases
taken actions against human trafficking
it's been a priority for the Department
of Justice and other agencies for some
time and we fully expect that in this
case and those like it there are going
to be actions to come how could there
not be this is the stuff of nightmares
and this is exactly the kind of thing
that law enforcement should be involved
in and we're committed to helping them
in that task but taking down an
institution like this is going to take
more than just one type of case whether
it's the government or a civil action
like the one that we've fought it's
going to take many things and many
different tools in the arsenal and is it
a kind of awakening then when you make
it public like this yes I think that
this I think that never before has the
full extent in this case of what this
organization has been involved in been
made clear in a public forum like this I
think that it will help open a lot of
people's eyes to what has been going on
and and we helped it it will it will
cause other survivors to come forward
and assist both law enforcement and
possibly bring their own cases
all right Josh Robbins in California and
Daniel Barker here in New York thank you
both for being with us here tonight
thank you Brian
and a reminder that our law and crime
Network will have full coverage of the
Weinstein case as it goes to the jury
next week
up next our shout out for the reporter
in Louisville whose stories helped to
curtail what was happening to innocent
black drivers in that city our shoutout
tonight goes to a veteran reporter in
Louisville Kentucky who's been a
journalist there for some four decades
but few of the stories have had the
impact of a powerful series he just
produced on what could only be called
the crime of driving while black you're
not running the stop iron
and you're gonna do what I tell you to
okay until the Louisville
courier-journal began to investigate
this was standard procedure for the
city's police violent crime unit black
motorist pulled over on traffic stops
and then ordered out of their cars often
put in handcuffs and then their vehicle
searched for drugs or weapons
courier-journal reporter Andrew Wolfson
documented the disturbing pattern we had
heard about this anecdotally but I
wanted to see if we could prove it we
found that the black square stopped
we had a proportion with whites even
though somewhat unexpectedly whites were
more likely to be found with guns and
other contraband and Wilson backed up
his research by obtaining police body
cameras to show just how it happened 18
year old Tian lei had no criminal
records and had just graduated from high
school where he was the homecoming king
when he was pulled over driving his
mother's car he was told he'd made a
turn that was too wide leave was pulled
out of his car mama they taking me out
the vehicle shouting to his mother on
his cell phone connection about what was
going on demanding to know from the
police why he was being treated this way
why are you checking me I didn't say you
did anything so you take me off the car
quit with the attitude he's not giving
you an attitude and I'm not giving you
an attitude we deal with violent crime
all day every day we're gonna stop 30
more people after you we're here for you
man
there's a shooting every day it's crazy
sad there was one officer in particular
who kept asking the young man why he has
such a bad attitude towards police as
they were standing him up in the hot Sun
an August day handcuffed behind his back
as the public drove by so it was it was
pretty outrageous in the case of Thien
ly police did not find any drugs or
weapons or anything other than an angry
mother who came to the scene to help her
son ma'am stay over there please if you
approach my traffic stop I will take you
to jail
either luckily enough for you ma'am
luckily enough for you
everything was captured on body camera
okay no let me end up for you oh really
okay we don't need his permission the
police chief said it was the only way to
get guns off the street and reduce the
city's rapidly escalating murder rate
and you talked to police experts who
said this is maybe lawful but not good
policing right
one part of it they said was clearly
unlawful and that was frisking this
young man without probable cause without
any evidence that he was armed and
dangerous in another case documented by
Wolfson and the courier-journal
Jamal Johnson an auto worker with no
criminal record was pulled over for an
issue with a turn signal y-you want to
step back here I think it was what was
unusual about his cases if I remember
correctly was it he was so suspicious of
police that he had his own camera a
video camera mounted in his in his car
so he captured his own stop the
courier-journal stories hit a nerve in
Louisville picked up by local television
this is the traffic stop that sparked
outrage in Louisville officers
questioned the team and asked to search
his car now the Louisville police chief
has issued new traffic stop rules to
restrict 10:00 cuffing and searches
these policies aim to strike a balance
between the concerns of the community
and the need for us to conduct traffic
stops from both safety and investigative
reasons I guess that was most I was
happy that it prompted two changes of
policy on to two separate fronts it's
rare to get results especially that
quickly so that was pleasing Andy Wilson
may be an old pro but he's still very
much at the top of
game that's our program for tonight
thanks for joining us we'll see you back
here in next week